speaking of bad have you guys heard of
this guy we have in charge supposedly of
the Country Joe Biden he is over in
Ireland right now he has Irish Roots so
he's very excited to be in Ireland and
uh here's just a portion of one of his
speeches while there and it's kind of
gross
all right there's nothing our Nations
can't achieve if we do it together I
really mean it so thank you all God
bless you all let's go let's go late and
let the world let's get it done
this is my favorite Biden quote yeah go
ahead I love this yeah just when you
think it can't get any worse or better I
don't know which word to use in this in
this context but that's it by the world
did he mean the ice cream cone like what
is going on here with it you could just
see it he does not know what's about to
come out of his mouth and then in this
case he was able to kind of Bring It
Around but often cannot do it lick the
world no it's like you know molestation
for everybody this is when the Gavin
Newsom is currently making his like
lizard people tour of the United States
it's like what if we did California
government but everywhere this is the
same thing it's like what if he you know
what if we did what Biden does to an ice
cream cone but to the whole world I mean
there is this sort of bizarre I think
ultimately Dave you you must be right
that there is something just kind of you
know there's a screw loose and we've
known this for a while he's sort of
daughtering around saying whatever comes
to mind and he doesn't have the luxury
of adjusting Pearson or a Justin Jones
to sort of take that long dramatic pause
he has to actually like put words in
front of one another and and I just want
to say to your point about uh you know
rhetorical excess you're absolutely
right and I was by the way like kidding
about insurrections you know this is
because I use the term insurrectiony or
it's it looks a little like an
Insurrection yeah but that's where you
know you draw the line to be very clear
that this is you know what happened in
Tennessee not now not January 6 and so
forth but yes by all means right no no
no I mean it's not it it's it's
certainly not the thing that January 6
has been made out to be but neither was
January 6 right very bad not a thing to
do but it wasn't this like kind of
massive inflated and so there is
something to be said I think
um for like for just laughing at these
people because this is I mean Biden the
Jones the Justin Jones is of the world
the Justin Pearsons of the world but
they really get off on most is this
incredible sincerity the gravitas the
just inviolable era of dignity that
you're not ever allowed to question or
or you know even raise an eyebrow at or
you're some kind of anti-americ American
insurrectionist right I mean this is
kind of how this stuff works and like if
nothing else for the sake of gallows
humor You Gotta Laugh a little bit when
the president United States says he
wants to to lick the world that's uh
that's pretty good well I'll tell you
guys this I I talked to a guy I know who
lives in Ireland because I just wanted
to get and he's he's very nonpartisan
very objective and I said you know Sean
what is the vibe there in Ireland are
you guys excited to see President Biden
I was asking about the the document
leaks is that overshadowing it and he
said look John um we actually you know
we're very thrilled anytime the American
president comes and I was somewhat
relieved by the fact that foreign
countries still have some respect for
the office at least of the American
president even though this guy is in it
right now which is important but I will
say just a promo my show coming up today
we have the meme Team every Friday and
you guys are always welcome to come on
and join us but one of the memes we're
going to feature today is a one from
Grand Old memes if you're familiar and
it's Joe Biden a mock-up on the Lincoln
Project logo but it's the licking
project
if you'd like more sane takes on our
insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell